[Musique]
oui dès 9h à l'offensive samedi puis
alors cette semaine vous pouvez imaginer
quel sujet je veux aborder c'est bien
sûr le faut
le faux débat autour des livres brûlés
par la commission scolaire catholique de
l'ontario pourquoi je dis faux débat
c'est que c'est un débat qu'on s'est
rendu compte n'incluait pas du tout les
communautés autochtones celles qui sont
touchés de près ou de loin par la
réécriture de l'histoire par des
cérémonies par le feu qui brûlait des
livres on s'entend que plusieurs
milliers de livres de bande dessinée ont
été brûlés au nom d'une meilleure
représentation des communautés
autochtones malheureusement on a aussi
appris assez rapidement que la personne
qui était au sein de ce comité là qui a
amené une espèce de validité et à
trouver des bonnes était n'est pas
nécessairement proche des communautés
autochtones puisque son ancêtre
remontait au xviiie siècle donc elle
avait un arrière arrière arrière grand
mère qui était assez commune d'ailleurs
pour une grande majorité des membres du
canada le sujet est en pole le sujet
étant que quand le suis c'est sorti dans
les médias tout de suite médias médias
sociaux commentaires dans les médias
sociaux ont fait le tour non seulement
de la province du pays mais aussi du nom
on a beaucoup ri justement de ce
processus là et ce qui a été vraiment le
bo qui blesse c'est que tout le
tout l'aspect d'une espèce de crise qui
était vécue à propos d'une approche qui
serait supposément autochtone a été
vécue par les communautés cependant les
communautés on okinawa où aucune apport
sur la conversation donc premièrement on
a vu tout de suite des petits drapeaux
rouges
abénakis montagneuses et naskapis ce les
trois communautés quel clan mais avoir
elle même et donc ta connais tu
fais non c'est assez rapide qu'on a fait
le tour et qu'on n'a pas pu relier mais
pas un cousin une matante un grand
parent à la dame deuxième drapeau rouge
comment est ce qu'une femme de ces trois
communautés leur sont plutôt situés au
québec peut avoir des actions aussi
directe en ontario sans consulter les
nations qui sont présentes dans une
absence complète de la communauté et il
dit départ un individu ça aussi c'est
quelque chose qui habituellement pour
des gestes de cette ampleur le amène des
drapeaux rouges ont fait les choses en
communauté on fait ce genre de cérémonie
très sérieusement en communauté je donne
des exemples quand on a brûlé les
mouchoirs des larmes pendant la
commission vérité-réconciliation c'était
une cérémonie mais s'étaient portés par
la communauté présentement au même d'une
cérémonie où on va brûler le défi des
mocassins qui avait été fait pour une
exposition pour parler des femmes
assassinées disparu et il y avait aussi
un volet pour les enfants des
pensionnats et là on parle de
communication extensible pendant des
années ou est-ce que les gens
d'exposition essayé de rejoindre tous
les fabricants des mocassins pour
demander ce que voulait ravoir les
dossiers des mocassins ou est ce que
vous voulez qu'ils finissent dans la
cérémonie du feu donc conversation
prix prise de temps discussions
autorisation tout a été fait vraiment
dans une perspective autochtone et ça a
été bien fait donc ces cérémonies ne
peuvent exister mais elles ne sont pas
faites à la va-vite ne sont pas faite
sans les communautés alors ça c'est un
autre drapeau rouge
vous en voulez des drapeaux rouges en on
a même le fait que c'est utilisé etc
instrumentalisée on a le temps des
élections pour parler du parti libéral
pour parler des comités autochtones pour
il ya eu une instrumentalisation d'un
moment de réappropriation de l'histoire
qui est importante pour les communautés
autochtones n'est pas d'effacement
d'histoire donc on a commencé à dire les
walk on a commencé à dire les libéraux
et tout ça a été fait sur le dos des
communautés autochtones qui les paie
même pas présent dans le débat donc ça
vous fait comprendre un peu la rage mais
aussi l'ironie de cette conversation là
à voir en 2021
un des sujets les plus drôles c'est une
des réponses et plus drôle que j'ai
entendu c'est pourquoi est-ce qu'on
aurait brûlé l'épreuve
donc c'est juste de dire le continuum de
l'histoire le contenu même si elle ne
nous avantage pas même si elle ne parle
pas de nous véritablement nous sert de
montrer aussi le processus que d'autres
ont utilisé pour parler de nous et nous
savons comment dire dès maintenant on va
s'éloigner de tout et ce qui est très
drôle c'est que la dame en question
utilisez une phrase extrêmement
important c'est à dire jamais de parler
de nous sans nous et ça c'est vrai que
c'est quelque chose qu'on demande
énormément mais quand c'est dit en plus
par une femme qui elle même des pottok
tonnes ça dit à quel point on peut être
vraiment retirer du débat et comment que
ça parle pas de nous mais plutôt des
autres donc on va continuer à parler de
ces sujets là parce qu'ils vont se
dévoiler de plus en plus parce que la
conversation justement autour du retour
de d'entités pour des membres de la
communauté qui ont été enlevés par le
sixty scoop c'est à dire hors des années
60 qui on passe à travers des
pensionnats qui ont eu les mariages qui
ont déconnecté justement les familles à
cause de la loi sur les indiens tout ça
ce sont des niveaux de co2 reconnexion
qu'on est en fait avant nous mêmes au
sein de nos propres communautés mais de
là à reconnecter avec les ossements tong
arrière arrière grand mère
sadi plus du désir de voir
avant du pouvoir sur la conversation des
autres plutôt que de toi ton
rapprochement donc n'hésitez pas à avoir
de la fierté pour l'identité que vous
avez n'hésitez pas à pas penser que d
ali ça veut dire nécessairement qu'on
doit retrouver des ancêtres autochtone
ces postulats conversation la
conversation c'est au tour de dire que
les cultures autochtones ont encore des
choses à dire on encore des sujets qui
sont assez chaud et qui ne sont pas
nécessairement à avoir sur les débats
publics sur les places publiques parce
que souvent ça amène ce genre de
situation là qui est assez ironique
merci donc
ils diraient pas merci beaucoup pour la
conversation mais je dirais par exemple
que ça vient réaffirmer ce besoin
d'avoir des personnes autochtones qui
sont nécessairement uniquement porteuse
d'une forme de parole qui plaît à
l'autre mais qui sont porteuses d'une
vérité d'une communication qui vient des
communautés qui portait en communauté
donc je vous souhaite une belle semaine
j'espère que la semaine prochaine on
aura des sujets plus joyeux assez
discuté ikivo nous inclure justement
dans la conversation